I want to connect this radius here with
this the length of the string and like
this angle that's up here at the top
okay so remember these are all in a
right angle triangle all right this is
the same length yes so what am I going
to use just use trick I've got the
radius down here
phears up there this is opposite over
hypotenuse
yes so I'm going to say but sine theta
sine theta is equal to opposite on
hypotenuse yeah so therefore this is
really nice because it sort of
simplifies this dramatically in one here
right therefore the tension is equal to
M Omega squared on our now you can see
the awesome cancel what's gonna happen
that help it's just gonna hop up into
the numerator so now you've got this is
that okay all right lovely so it is the
tension in this string right now I asked
you all to get your stream and to UM
attach it now don't spin it just yet
okay what I want you to my goodness okay
I'm gonna stand back okay now what I
want you to notice as we as we do this
okay the first thing I want you to do is
just get your object just get it
rotating very slowly can you do that
just get it rotating pretty slow okay
now I want you to feel the tension in
the string
okay can you feel it it's pulling away
from your fingers okay if you let go
okay yeah well you need to you need to
attach it to something okay because this
is a light string yeah
now here's what I want you to notice
don't do it just yet think about what
happens at the moment the mass of your
object is not changing the length of
your string is not changing but this is
quite easy to change right it's quite
easy to change now if we were to don't
do it just yet if we were to increase
this what would you predict what
happened here now think about it right
so okay go ahead and make your thing
spin faster and can you feel the tension
in the string
okay now he's it's really interesting
right if just stop it maybe remove it if
you just leave it there
right it's stationary so we've got near
this first law right so you got gravity
gone that way all right wait what's
going that way and you've got tension in
the string going this way they exactly
balance it's not moving okay you can
still feel feel that that force okay
but now as you do it again spin it up
spin it up and then whew what happens
make sure you're secure okay as well as
you feel it going faster and faster can
you feel it wanting to break away okay
now remember and you can slow it down
again you slow it down again
yeah oh okay your finger is relaxed and
what have you
now I want you to remember when we were
on I'll just use this when we were on
the basketball courts okay now several
times several times right you are doing
this and then yo what happened to your
life your life just kind of Berta pot
right why why did it break a pot what
was it make it made a break a pot so you
are holding yourself together right your
angular velocity overcame the tension in
the string okay and that's why you flew
apart okay if the thing couldn't that
the body of them that if the line of
bodies couldn't hold itself together
anymore and so it's like okay does that
make sense okay now just one more time
as you as you increase angular velocity
tension increases that's no surprise
okay but there's something else that
changes right as you increase angular
velocity you should find remember we
said earlier there was no vertical
movement right but if I spin it fast
enough
there is vertical movement right what
happens as Omega increases
Vidar theta can speak up Haidee gets
bigger okay now another way so you can
stop that I can put that down another
way I say that feely gets bigger is that
this hike in a perpendicular height of
your object your mass from wherever the
string is that gets smaller okay so my
question to you is how can we show that
this is the case not just like
experientially but how can we actually
yeah fantastic so I've got this angle
here right this guy is changing too so I
don't want to muck with that I don't
relate h2r because they're both changing
I would much prefer to relate h2o okay
now even though even though I'd prefer
to do that because I already have
expressions for what all these are I
can't actually relate it up watch this
here's the thing I'm going to say what
about what about page so I'm gonna go
off to R because I already have ironed a
whole variety of spaces so I'm gonna say
tan feed on equals what is tape it up H
it's fine
dramas but remember I told you before
these two equations are they're going to
be important thing any of the important
here's why I'm pulling our town right
that I got from the right angle triangle
okay but these I got from my forces do
you see 10 do you see it there I'm gonna
do 2/1 okay so I'm gonna say this is
from just writing a tree but 2/1 these
two equations gives me on the right hand
side T's cancel sine theta and cos theta
that's
when I divide this by this mass cancels
you get R Omega square on gene yep
so let's let's pull this over okay what
I've got now is our H equals R Bermuda
square on G what would you like me to do
remember I'm trying to understand H I'm
gonna cancel than ready so this is
independent of the radius that's
interesting and then you can see this is
just one on H right so that means H is
equal to Omega square the way we would
say this is that the height that
vertical distance there is inversely
proportional to the square of the
angular velocity right angular velocity
goes up high it gets smaller right which
is why do it one more time for just for
the second right make sure you secure as
you spin it faster right it has to go up
it has to go up right you're not pulling
it up it's going up because of this okay
and of course if you slow it down
decreasing Omega is going to increase
the fun does that make sense
it's pretty freakin awesome okay all
right so that's the basic idea for the
critical pendulum okay
I want you to underline a couple of
things with me can you underline this
guy I underlined at all this this is the
F equals MA of the conical pendulum and
I don't mean that figuratively I mean it
literally that F equals MA this is your
acceleration over here okay so if you
see a conical pendulum diagram to give
away right this is what your style
well you could change as you force it
into the velocity and then once you got
angular velocity you can work at tension
so exactly by the way quick thing you
noticed I said oh yeah you know you
can't you can't change length your
string just spontaneously you can't but
you can't just you know wind up and make
it a bit shorter okay now this is for a
second if the string is shorter
who is that mean it will experience less
tension those experience less tension or
if you maintain the same amount of
tension and reduce the link what happens
to this
it increases angular velocity increases
now we've all seen this before if you've
ever seen the Winter Olympics and you
see Olympic figure skaters right what
they do is this spinning they're
spinning and then they pull in their
body right it which is effectively
shortening the length of the string and
so because they're sure that this is
going to stay the same so angular
velocity its skyrocket symmetrical like
crazy okay they're taking advantage of
this principle so make sense
and